Supreme Court had a busy week and one of
the things they did is from the New York
Post Supreme Court overturns New York
law on carrying concealed weapons so
let's just remind people what happened
here you can scroll down writing for the
sixth three majority Justice Clarence
Thomas said Thursday that the Law's
requirement of New Yorkers who want a
permit to carry a handgun in public to
show proper cause that the weapon is
specifically needed for self-defense
violates the 14th Amendment it does by
preventing law-abiding citizens with
ordinary self-defense needs from
exercising their right to keep and bear
arms in public
so essentially they said why do you have
to prove why you shouldn't have to it's
a violation of the 14th Amendment of
course everybody in New York lost their
minds though
so who in New York
lost their minds let's take a guess
Kathy clueless Kathy remember clueless
Kathy hokel you remember her the
governor of New York well she lost her
mind completely about this and she was
confronted by Anne a news anchor and
journalist what is I don't have her last
name McCloy Ann McCoy here it is Ann
McCloy who did a great job showed up to
a press conference and asked some
questions we have a video clip of Kathy
hokel do we have that clip guys where we
can play
okay here it is let's play a little bit
of the Q a that went back and forth
between Anne who has a completely
legitimate question actually two and
Kathy's response shall we let's go
do you have the numbers to show that
it's the concealed carry permit holders
that are committing crimes because the
lawful gun owner will say that you're
attacking the wrong person it's really
people that are getting these guns
illegally that are causing the violence
not the people going and getting
the permit legally and that's the basis
for the whole Supreme Court argument do
you have the numbers I don't need to
have numbers
I don't need I don't have to have a data
point to point to to say that this is
going to make a lot okay can we pause
that for a second she doesn't have the
numbers
data
she doesn't have the numbers or the data
to support in any way that it's the
people who have Concealed Carry Permits
and that they're the problem because
they're not obviously criminals don't
say oh I need a concealed carry permit
let me let me just hold on a second I'll
get to that bank robbery in just one
second let me just fill out a paper just
give me a second that's not how it works
Kathy and I'm starting to realize you
know I call her clueless Kathy she's not
clueless she knows exactly what she's
doing this isn't the destruction is
intentional in New York don't think that
it isn't
so much like everything else that Kathy
supported in New York with tanked she's
she's tanking the state it's not hot
it's harder to tank the state than the
city but Kathy is quite Adept at doing
that she didn't have stats to support
Mass mandates
and have stats to support vax mandates
they don't exist
she didn't have stats to support
extended lockdowns
but the best part about this is that she
says it
I don't have this the stats
why would I need the stats I can just
Implement policy based off of a
ridiculous talking point and everyone
will Pat me on the back in New York
because everyone's a Walking Dead robot
that's lost their minds
you know in The Walking Dead how people
get bit and they're just like
Welcome to New York hope you enjoy your
stay
all right
do we have that clip again can we pull
it up I just want to play the end of the
clip because Anne
makes a great point at the end we can
continue
do you have sensible gun safety laws and
this one was not devised by the local
Administration it comes out of an
Administration from 1908 I don't need a
data point to make the case that I've
heard responsibility people of this
state somebody who's going to go do a
mass shooting or something like that may
not go get a concealed carry I never
said there's any correlation between our
solution here and the Buffalo case okay
so you know Ann is trying to do her job
of just saying like hey
um almost trying to help her out like
hey do you have any
support for what you're do if you have
it this would be the time to share it no
and that's what you need to know about
what's happened the last two years is
that this is how they got away with what
they got away with and they did
they did because people laid down and
took it so she feels totally justified
that she can come out now she can
criminalize law abiding concealed carry
people in New York City in New York in
the state of New York who say you know
what I don't like the crime on the
streets I don't like what's going on I
don't like the way you make the police
force feel real small
that's not going to work for me I'm
going to take matters into my own hands
I'm going to go to the range I'm going
to get the proper certifications I'm
going to get my background check and I'm
going to defend myself my child my
family
she's now got to make them out to be the
bad guy even though she has no stats to
support that those are actually the bad
guys because it's a convenient talking
point so just know that everything you
laid down for the last two years when
you had to shut down your business and
many of you picked up and left New York
and came out to Florida or you had to
put a mask on your four-year-old's face
to go to school when your kid was not at
risk for this disease and those masks
were proven to be completely and utterly
useless in most settings and in most
cases because of the masks that were
used the way that we're used and the
fact they just weren't working
we have plenty of data on that Kathy
so when you did all that when you went
and maybe got a vaccine that you didn't
want because you were going to lose your
job because they were telling you oh the
vaccine was going to keep everybody safe
and then you find out well it doesn't
prevent transmission what the hell's
going on here ask questions and it will
stop when you stop accepting this
nonsense and when you stop start saying
oh you don't have the data okay we're
not going to do that anymore
we she works for the people of New York
not the other way around
not the other way around so she can take
that cocky attitude and she can walk
right out the door I would have had some
words if I were in that room good on and
by the way for keeping her composure
that's why I don't have that job just
putting that out there if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]